you're so committed to your sort of
comedy and life that that you for a time
and I don't know what to point in your
life you rented out your apartment and
you decided to live on the streets oh
yeah when when I first moved to New York
I was like I gotta sacrifice myself for
comedy like existence is suffering man
you were you stand-up comic was a fan of
comics yeah right when I moved to New
York City right 22 23 years old and the
idea was I'm gonna give up my apartment
just for this summer I was like it's my
first summer in New York my friend Julio
was coming into town I was like I'll
rent out my apartment to him for a
little bit more than I pay for it and
write use that extra money to just eat
food and I was like sleeping outside and
sleeping on couches I would do stand-up
at night and ask the audience if I could
sleep over and didn't you take your
toothbrush and plant the toothbrush at
different friend's house I had like 12
to thrush is all around the city any
idea what you would sleep in the park
right I would either stay up all night
and sleep in the park during the day but
or get drunk and sleep in the park at
night but I only slept at a partly anvil
and would you get rolled by the police
like would they know I'm you like fall
asleep at midnight drunk in the park and
then at like 5:00 in the morning I'd
wake up terrified and be like this is a
horrible plan what the hell am I
thinking and I was like to go to a
friend's house that like mine am like
hey can I sing and what was the point a
job I was like I need to I was like if
I'm gonna make it as a comedian I need
to just focus on comedy I can't get
stuck in a day job so been living animal
s life you could I just wanted to like
not have a temp job I just wanted to
like orient my mind like this is it this
is what I'm doing my offer for but I
would think the suffering causes so much
angst that you can't even think of
anything funny because I mean you really
it's an uncomfortable exists it was kind
of a thrill I couldn't do it now but for
this summer when you're 22 years old
you're resilient you know over your
friends like they were ours did your
friends think they needed to do an
intervention in some ways I mean for the
most part I was sleeping on couches but
every once in a while I couldn't find a
couch or could been somebody in the
audience to let me sleep over so I would
agree to yourself that hey no matter how
bad things get I can at least survive
is that part of it I don't know I think
it was just a way to avoid having a job
one of the bits you once did was you
tried to feed a homeless guy lo mein on
a subway and the guys smashed the food
in your face he wasn't homeless I went
into you know this kid there's kids that
sell like M&Ms and stuff on the subway
for their basketball team so I went on
the subway hidden camera and I said
ladies and gentlemen pardon the
interruption I'm selling Chinese food
for my basketball team by shoving lo
mein in people's faces because
uppercutting the [ __ ] but you could
understand that right when a guy throws
the lo mein back in your face do you
think right away oh [ __ ] this is
dangerous or do you think good bit I
think great bit